hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
preview the upcoming Yellowjackets
Episode by looking at the promo trailer
and photos and all the other stuff
that's floating around out there on the
internet if any of that sounds like
spoilers to you or you're just not into
wild speculation on what might happen in
Yellowjackets season 2 episode 5 then
this video won't be for you I've heard
nothing but wonderful things about you
what are you doing here Ty
allow yourself to go back what do you
see
[Music]
the title is two truths and a lie which
refers to a game or maybe a team
building exercise where someone
introduces three things about themselves
two of which are true and then the other
players have to try to figure out which
one is a lie it's probably most
interesting when all three things sound
equally as outrageous or unbelievable
because that makes it hard to figure out
which one is false I'm not sure how this
fits into whatever's happening in this
episode because it's somewhat vague as
is the episode description which reads
okay fellow jackets rise and shine and
don't forget your booties because it's
cold out there Missy makes a leap of
faith for her bestie Natalie and Lottie
play a game of surrender Shauna finds
herself unexpectedly Randy and Ty seeks
out a movie recommendation the trailer
opens with Lottie talking to the others
outside of the cabin with everyone
sitting in a circle she says a new life
is coming and we can't wait to meet him
in the photos of this it looks like
everyone one is there except Nat and
Shauna and we see the latter watching
from a distance she turns her head to
give you the sense that she doesn't like
what's happening but it's not readily
apparent what's bothering her because it
all looks innocent enough they're
holding hands in one shot they're
closing their eyes but none of it looks
all that off-putting it looks like the
beginnings of some of the stuff we'll
see the cult doing down the road and I
mentioned that in my episode 1 video
about the blessing she was giving Travis
in that Lottie is a teenager with no
real experience in being a spiritual
leader a lot of what she was doing there
felt like she was just trying out stuff
that she was Vaguely Familiar with it's
all well-intentioned none of it's
innately Sinister but based on what she
told the therapist in episode 204 we
know that that might change Sana has
been mostly quiet since they ate Jackie
which makes it hard to tell where she's
at as she gets closer to her delivery
date but she was noticeably spooked by
the symbol a lot of put on the blanket
at the shower so maybe her maternal
instinct is kicking in this scene just
appears to show how things will continue
to split inside the group and you do see
that Tai has a skeptical look on her
face while she's sitting in the circle
they made a point to show that Lottie is
in power hungry though in the last
episode and then you also had Mari that
was pushing this idea that Hobbies
return was evidence that Lottie has what
amounts to special powers it's notable
that hobby doesn't show up in any of the
photos or the trailer so we don't get
any hints about how the group's gonna
react to him being back at the cabin or
how the explanation of how he survived
that long on his own will change things
there really isn't any evidence that
he's there at all in any of the
promotional material the one thing you
can pick up on is that his return wasn't
good for teen Nat standing within the
group she looks isolated there's one
shot of her looking sad while she's
talking to coach Ben who's become an
outsider in his own own right which
makes sense because they were close in
the past Travis is sitting in the circle
without her and I imagine he's upset
about what she did with the bloody pants
it seems like she'll have some work to
do to regain everyone's trust adult net
has a lot going on though we see her
talking to Misty and Walter after they
arrive at the Gate of lottie's compound
Nat asks who he is and he introduces
himself saying that he's heard nothing
but wonderful things about her it
wouldn't be surprising if she was
suspicious of Walter the situation was
different but we saw how she treated the
other citizen detective she met and we
don't actually see Nat let them inside
and they don't show up in any of the
other photos that have Lottie in them
because of what they have on this
appears to be connected to the clip that
was in the season 2 trailer where he
says kidnapping Cults death your
friendships are a little more
complicated than most beyond that no
idea if they get inside or what they
would do instead if they don't I imagine
the line from the description that says
Misty takes a leap of faith for her
bestie is referring to Nat and what
transpires here but it could also apply
to the 96 timeline which we'll come back
around to we also finally get this
sequence where Lottie is doing a session
with Nat you see her Flash the pen light
on her and tell her to allow herself to
go back and she asked her what she sees
in the season 2 promo she answers
darkness and that they brought it back
with them and in another trailer you
hear more where she says that the whole
time there was a Darkness out there you
also see that she puts her head on
lottie's lap and it changes so that you
see Team net doing that so this appears
to be a breakthrough for the character
if not their relationship but we'll have
to see where this goes because in the
photos it does look like she uses those
keys that she was holding at the end of
the episode to look through lottie's
stuff there are shots of her looking
through documents and folders and then
several shots where it looks like there
might be a confrontation I imagine that
that will happen first that that will be
the inciting incident to get this
session going and maybe that will then
clear the air there's a quick shot of
candles blowing out and I think that
might be connected to that and there's
also one quick flash of the antler Queen
walking through the plane after the
crash which looks like a vision
obviously you see some Flames behind her
and I don't know what else that might be
connected to if not this
Cali comes into the kitchen to talk to
her parents and says remember when you
asked if I told anyone promise you won't
freak out and Jeff says sure and they
have a pretty surprised look on their
faces this is probably just her
introducing the idea that she's dating
an older guy I mean her parents can't
really say anything about her choices
now that she knows their secrets and we
do see her in Jay's car and on a date
with him at the bowling alley because it
doesn't seem like Shawna and Jeff and
the whole family are going to go to
prison for Adam's murder it doesn't seem
likely that she would have told him
about anything other than the affair but
it's also obvious from other trailers
that they're eventually going to get
called in to answer questions I really
don't know what to expect from this
since shawna's probably not going to go
to prison what is this for if Cali told
Jay something serious then they would
probably have to kill him for it to make
sense and I don't really see it going
that way either because they would be
the biggest suspects if that happened I
also don't really know why teen Shawna
and Ty team up but it looks like they
get caught away from the cabin in a
storm it's probably connected to Shauna
looking uncomfortable with whatever
Lottie was doing with the rest of the
group but I'm not sure how to connect
the dots in a way that if she was
worried about the baby she would go
wandering around in the forest it looks
like a pretty bad storm though we see
van yelling their names from the porch
of the cabin as they are walking in the
storm we also see her watching Lottie
while she has her eyes closed during the
storm so there's a little bit more of
that trying to will something to happen
like we saw in the last episode whenever
she was in the hunting competition the
piece that's missing here might be
related to hobby whatever was going on
with him but I don't have any real great
ideas on it most of the theories and
guesses that I saw didn't really add up
so we'll see what happens there was a
clip in another trailer where Shauna
tells her that she needs her to have her
back but there's no indication of why we
hear adult then asked Ty why she's there
what she's doing there and she just
shakes her head like she doesn't know I
mentioned in my last video I think she
thinks she might be able to help her
figure out why she's sleepwalking again
and in the second shot it looks like van
is standing there with the bad one there
are no additional photos of these two in
the present day and I'm pretty
interested to see what they say to each
other there's a quick shot of teen Thai
and Akila messing around while they're
washing clothes in the tub but there
isn't any context about what's happening
maybe the most intriguing shot in this
trailer is this one a misty looking over
a ledge by itself it's not much it could
be just about anything but this might be
a tragic event or I might just be trying
to connect a bunch of random things
together there was a trailer they put
out after the premiere that showed
scenes from the whole season in that you
see Misty talking to Crystal wearing
these same clothes she's says she has a
secret a ginormous one and my first
thought when I saw that was that she was
referring to destroying the flight
recorder because that was the biggest
secret she had in season one her saying
that and knowing that if that got out
the rest of the group would turn on her
even more like they might just kill her
because they don't like her anyway all
of that made it seem like this would put
Crystal in danger if Misty confided in
her we've seen them getting closer
they're obviously tight friends now and
we've seen Crystal confide some things
like absorbing her twin and they both
agreed that they kind of enjoyed eating
Jackie there's a bunch of promo photos
of these two hanging around doing what
they've been doing looking happy
together in the cabin and then there's a
couple of them where Mari is holding up
a deck of cards making them draw from it
we know that they do this for some
things we know that Misty was having to
go get the water and we expect because
we saw the queen of hearts that there
will be bigger implications for this
down the the road here it looks like
Crystal draws a two which is probably
bad if the low card has to do some chore
that no one else wants to do but she
still has a smile on her face so maybe
Misty agreed to help her so you have
Misty alone on this ledge looking over
and since it's always felt possible that
she might end up killing Crystal over
the secret anyway you can't help but
think that this might be when it happens
it's snowing and there was a similar
shot where she was crying in a similar
situation and the other thing is that
these are the same clothes Misty's
wearing when they're carrying the body
that's tied to the stick to add to this
in the shot where they're standing on
the porch of the cabin and Van is
yelling for Ty and Shauna Misty is there
but Crystal isn't by her side two things
that go against this idea are that the
person on the stick is wearing Converse
and Crystal is wearing something
different in the pictures where they're
drawing cards and Jen and Melissa are
also missing from the port shot so the
whole group isn't exactly there I don't
though I look through the other trailers
and the promo photos for episode six and
didn't see any shots of Crystal that
come after this but as I mentioned in
the beginning there aren't any of hobby
either might be something big might be
nothing and I think that's a great place
to leave things please like this video
If you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon